hi and welcome to the fourth episode of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm Franciscan boy and I'm here with my
co-host mark hi mark how are you doing
I'm doing well friend says how are you
doing pretty good pretty good trying to
fight the jet lag what about you were
you mark I'm in San Francisco it's
relatively early on a Saturday morning
here in my living room that's a great
place to be that's pretty that's a nice
place to be um well I'm where are you
hiding I'm actually hiding somewhere in
the South of France I mean on my way
from paris to barcelona where i'll be
next week okay that sounds really really
fun sounds like you're getting your
travel on saturday afternoon podcast
recording fun fun well that's pretty
exciting so we have a we have a Back to
the Future moment we have an interview
that's gonna come up that hasn't even
been done yet yeah so actually I'm going
to Barcelona as I said and going there
for dr. Khan where I will be keeping a
line talk but even more important than
that i will be interviewing jesse
Frizzell one of the contributors
actually one of the team members of the
docker engine team where she's gonna be
talking to us I hope cuz I still don't
know but she will be talking to us about
containers what's all the fuss about and
how you get started it sounds like
that's gonna be a really interesting
interview i look forward to listening to
me i look forward to actually doing that
interview what who so we have I think a
pretty cool cool thing of the week and
this week can definitely something
that's it see in your wheelhouse because
it has to do with go yeah it does um we
will yeah we released the google cloud
debugger for her recently yep uh which
is in my opinion a great thing to have
uh I could not have named their dad
because first time I heard about a
debugger on production I was slightly
scared about having break points oh my
that does sound scary yeah i'm just
going to start my processes yeah
but it doesn't it doesn't do that at all
actually so basically what the cloud
debugger does both for java and go we
have it for for both languages now is
that for any application that is running
on google compute engine you basically
set it up first and then it will allow
you to add break points but actually
those are not real break bones those are
snapshot point so oh so it like takes a
picture of what's going on in your
system so you can see what's like
happening with like you variables in
your call stack and things actly so you
can add you can add some conditions so
you you don't want to take any snapchat
for instance you can say oh yeah I want
to take a snapshot of this lining this
for loop when the index variable is 42
and that's it so oh that's actually
really bad that's great it's really
powerful it will allow you to see what
is the value of all the other variables
in the scope at that point and also the
call stack so you'll be able to
understand not only what you're going
what you're doing but also how you got
there so that's pretty powerful yeah so
i haven't played with it but i'm
guessing people gonna be like so is
there a performance issue here is there
something you know i'm running in
production is that a problem it's
actually not a problem taking snapshots
will have a very very tiny impact on
your performance uh but it's actually
good enough that if you have an issue I
could definitely not even think about it
just go for it try it for sure don't
leave it on taking snapshots every
second because it's not really useful
but it's something that it's definitely
worth the performance cost because also
when you the performance cast is only
link to the point when you actually use
it when you're not using it you don't
have a performance class so you're good
yeah and and obviously that performance
cost is worth it to solve whatever that
issue is that you're having and if you
have to do it on production it's
probably like a really tricky issue
exactly it's it's basically on the order
of magnitudes of milliseconds like I
don't know if it's like a run 5
milliseconds after that which is
definitely worth it like there's worse
things that could happen to your firm
action really so and it's going to allow
you to basically find the good values
for you to test on your code outside of
production and then there you can
actually use an actual debugger and go
stay back
they understand what's exactly the farm
with code or even better run a bunch of
unit tests demonstrating that your code
is wrong then fix it and fix your test
with that ya know that sounds yeah is
that sometimes here are just those
tricky issues like race conditions that
you couldn't bring up in unit tests are
tricky to bring up in your test so you
didn't think of stuff that really like
it only shows up in production because
that's the best place for things to show
up obviously but these things happen so
it's it's good to have those tools it's
good that you mentioned race conditions
it's actually something that I've been
talking lately about so when you have
raised conditions and go one of the best
things that you can do is use the data
the data race detector which is as
simple as it's as simple to use as when
you build vehicle your binary ash dash
dash race that's it that's everything
you need to do and then it generates a
binary that will detect any time there's
a race detect data race when that
happens it will emit a warning so with
that then you can basically every single
time such a warning appears you can
analyze you logged and file a bug or
something like that so that you can fix
it if you do that though you have to be
careful because it's not like it doesn't
take snapshots it's actually much slower
so slow it will slow down your process
quite a bit even though when there's no
races no data races which means that
it's something that you might want to do
as a side server like you have a test
server that it's getting maybe some
shadow traffic from production it's
actually trying to handle those and if
it takes longer it's not really fun
because maybe it's not impacting the
production's the production traffic just
getting some of that traffic and if
something goes wrong files about
directly so that's also very useful
technique there you go one cool cloud
thing one cool go there you go extra
extra cool great so I think that it's
probably time to bring jesse from the
future and start talking with her about
containers what do you think sounds
great excited to hear
okay so we're here with Jesse Frizzell
hi Jesse hi so we're here at Khan and so
that's the doctor con EU in Barcelona
the second duct work on that has it
happened yes the second of the European
conferences there's also two that
happened in the US great so we've been
here is the second day and as far as I
soon jesse is not only a one known
person in the docker community in San
Francisco but pretty much everywhere
else so I wanted to know a little bit
more about what you do a docker to be so
famous I'm not famous I am a core
maintainer so I think that actually that
has a lot to do with it it's some open
source project and it gets a lot of
visibility and i also am contributing a
lot of code for it most recently have
been working on adding set comp to dr.
itself which a lot of people have wanted
and i helped try to get in the user name
space pull request which was also
heavily requested so yeah we work a lot
on go and open source in general nice i
saw that there was some statistics about
the number of a pull request that you
get per week how many are those um we
get around 200 per week and actually we
have um like even cooler stats um my
coworker are no wrote this really cool
like go tool that will get all the open
source tests and i found out that i am
the person who closes not merges the
most polar request oh so maybe that's
why your favorite list yeah maybe not
just a good thing after so and how long
you be working at docker um alo it over
a year no um I started in September but
my first contribution was last June or
like the June before that so yeah that's
how I like he came up that's great so
how did you start how did you get
started with containers like containers
have been a something really important
like the new hot thing in the tech
industry for quite a while why did you
get interested on it
so the startup I was working at before
docker we actually used a Lexi and
Alexia is it works but it's just kind of
painful to use um so we switched to
docker at 0.5 which was kind of rough
but still better than Alexi so then I
started getting into the project i
started watching the repo and um one
thing led to another that's very cool so
you started using docker a little bit
because you were already using
containers lxc it's kind of like
container just not as easy to use
basically totally uh why why did someone
start using containers as the company
like how what is the benefit of running
containers rather than just everything
directly number made up so it allows
like your infrastructure to be easily
transported from dev into production
because you can run it on your Mac you
can run it anywhere and actually in the
first keynote at dr. Khan they showed
like a new developer starting on their
first day all they have to spin up on
their laptop is docker itself instead of
having to get like the whole company
stack like Python Ruby all that crap and
yeah that's very nice yeah yeah it's
basically getting people like the
development environment instead of the
container also yeah that's really cool
so I think that rather than spending
time talking about why people should
move to containers because I at this
point I'm pretty sure the like master
people actually think that that's a good
idea I could like to talk about how do
you do that so like if you were to move
a company from like traditional stack
two containers why could be the first
steps yeah so I would say it would be to
start you know taking apart you're like
monolithic things into the database
running that in a container by itself
whatever proxy you have running that in
a container so just really separating
out the micro services and then starting
to play around with them maybe the
doctor command line and then maybe
playing around with the new like
platform-as-a-service tools but all
these
burn things that have come to like
fruition yeah we had last week we had an
interview with Brian Dorsey he worked
for the Cooper and his team and it was
quite interesting because he was
basically talking about yeah like once
you go through that step of going from
one my mother too thick add to you have
also a bunch of containers and micro
services and everything all of a sudden
there's a new set of problems that sit
in so basically like that that's when
you're gonna be talking about like swarm
or Cooper Nattie's or missiles or
whatever stock that you want to use and
there's somebody to choose from now it's
like the world is at your disposal huh
yeah that's that's really cool it's kind
of scary I think that at some point we
should have an episode talking about
what to do yeah what are the options
there I think it's quite an interesting
topic so you mentioned at the beginning
of the top something that I believe in
your interview mentioned sac comp
security is quite a big deal I've seen
people putting private keys inside of
containers and on public repos that's
kind of dangerous ah so tell us a little
bit about what do you think that we
should always take care of that
regarding to carry with containers yeah
so what I'm working on right now is the
first phase is actually set comp itself
which is a allow or denying certain
syscalls you can actually even trace um
it's uh but the first phase is actually
going to be like this kind of not so
easy to use config but not so complex as
something as a farmer or something like
that but the second phase of that is
actually one config to rule all security
profiles and then it will have different
backends like using set comp or a farmer
or selinux labels so you get the ability
to like log on right on any file or deny
files being written to allow like
certain executables to run like ptrace
stuff like that nice so basically the
idea is that the same way we have like
with us to you have scopes and you allow
people to do one thing or the other it's
kind of the same thing but inside of off
Linux right
yeah totally it was actually designed um
and inspired by the Apple api's and also
androids ap is for security scopes cool
yeah I've seen I saw your demo your
landing talk at not that Fox but the the
docker meet up in Belgium right that
that was that was really interesting i
wonder if that was recorded visual if it
was recorded out tried to put the link
to that on a show notes ah cool so I'm
gonna say it again but you're kind of
famous for one hot cific thing which is
running everything in a container like
I've seen you're running like normal
things like chrome but also I've seen
you even launching games from steam on a
container which is pretty awesome and
like it's it's really amazing the fact
that you're able to do that people tend
to say like oh yeah that's too hard but
then you make it look easy so I wanted
to ask you what is the next crazy thing
you're gonna do or if there's no crazy
thing that you can disclose what is one
crazy thing that you've tried and
totally fail um so my coworker or no and
I gave a talk yesterday and we had this
crazy idea of fitting a docker image
onto a 1.4 for megabyte floppy disk and
it was all going to go so perfectly i
ordered this floppy disk to USB
converter and I like translate the page
from Spanish so that i could make sure
that it written on linux and I like
plugged it in when we got it and it was
just like totally borked like back in
the olden days when you would put in
your floppy disk and you just knew it
wasn't working right it was like the
exact same sound so we were like well
but we did create an image that was
small enough to fit on one and like the
coolest part about it actually was at
the binary that was in the image was a
go binary built statically so we could
build from scratch and the binary itself
was like five megabytes which is way too
big it's never gonna fit but then when
you put it in the docker image itself
and you do a docker say
it will create a tarball but that tar
ball isn't compressed so actually what
we did was on tar it then reetar it with
XZ and like nine compression the maximum
and it was 1.3 mega nice so okay that's
actually very interesting can you
actually do that in general like you
once you have a docker image on tired
and then tied with compression and the
docker demon will be able to handle it
like if it was a normal image yeah so
you can actually so that eggsy
compressed image I could have dr. loaded
it back in so it actually would be
really nice if on docker save we could
pass a flag like use this compression
level like either gzip XZ and like what
sort of yeah very nice because nowadays
one of the problems that that I have is
if I try to run docker on my machine and
have like a hotel Wi-Fi a conference
Wi-Fi it's kind of a pain cuz images
tend to be quite big right so that could
maybe help with that yeah totally and
that would be a huge help that's pretty
awesome the other option of course is
using docker machine yeah which yeah
there's there's actually we put on the
links one of my co-workers preity Rodin
we're a blog post about how to use
docker with a conference hotel with a
conference Wi-Fi oh my god that's so
good yeah so basically you started
instant somewhere like an Google cloud
platform and then you connected that it
works really really well that's what I
do all the time that's perfect okay so
you mentioned something that didn't work
the floppy disk tell us about something
that you think it's it's cool that
you've seen lately cool um yeah so
actually the stuff with x server that i
do is all just mounting locally my x11
socket but you can also actually do this
entirely remotes on a server so say you
have Wireshark which is has like a GUI
running on a server you can have a the
remote VNC connection and actually show
it locally on your local instance so I
think that that's kind of neat and also
like the fact that you can like the
difference between VMs and containers
um sharing namespaces so the fact that
you can have a wire for container
connected to a different container
sharing the same network namespace you
can actually look at all the packets
from the other container without
exposing everything from your host to
the Wireshark container itself so just
the fact that dr. allows you to share
like net namespaces pin namespaces it's
like super helpful in terms of debugging
and the whole like remote VNC x11 thing
is also helpful in terms of debugging so
there's two really cool things in there
one is the fact that so what you're
saying is that you have your containers
that is running somewhere and like that
it's not aware of why shark or anything
just running there I wanted the bucket
and without modifying that container
you're able to start a new container
that will be sniffing those packets with
wireshark yeah so you can actually take
the network name space from the
container that you want to debug and
then run the next container let's say
your Wireshark container or like maybe
even the strays container in that
Network namespace and if it was strace
he could actually run it in the pin
namespace of the other container which
is like really that's fascinating yeah
that's really fun so basically you can
connect to that container with that
content that container that you want to
investigate doesn't need to know
anything you don't need to restart it or
anything just yeah connect there so it
like annihilates the whole need to like
exec and install other and then do what
you need to do you don't need to exact
anymore you can be sure that your
debugging tools won't to modify the
original container nice and yeah and so
that was one of the first not one of the
cool things really cool thing that that
that implies is that you can be running
graphical you is curious on a server and
access them like they were local
applications on your laptop yeah right
so that's through xserver which means
that on Linux it works really well what
about Mack yeah Mac would be interesting
I think it would probably have to use
may be the same hack that is used when
people try to run my stuff on
um there max and it involves like a so
cat into like in x11 Mac instance and
then it fires into the vm I mean I'm not
really sure about the technical details
but of it's something like magic it
sounds quite complicated is there any
blockbuster or something that you could
point by my suit yeah there's actually
an issue um that is closed now but on
docker itself where someone is
mentioning my GUI and I think it's like
titled like mac OS x x 11 and the person
who figured it out posted all the
details and actually i'll get emails
still on this issue of people thinking
the guy who figured it out it must all
work and it was still be legit ok so
i'll check it out now a bad link also to
the show notes that sounds really
interesting nice so do you think you
could be then doable to have something
like you have a pretty small computer
like a like a i get tiny micro computer
even my raspberry pi maybe like imagine
that you have a raspberry pi you want to
run a quite powerful application that
requires cpu could you be doing
something where like you just care you
just have your x11 server running on the
Raspberry Pi and then the rest of
computation is actually sent to some
container running somewhere else and I
like you can have like a Google cloud
platform you can have like 32 course if
you want to so you could be running make
it very very powerful application and a
good look like it's running on the
Raspberry Pi yeah totally I mean you
could use VNC and do that and yeah that
would actually be a really cool idea
especially in terms of the whole
conference Wi-Fi thing yeah you just
have the most minimal stuff locally and
then everything else is just hitting a
remote instance yeah i will definitely
try that that sounds actually really
interesting cool so to finish i wanted
to talk a little bit more about your
relationship with the darker community
so you said that you started working as
a while you started contributing before
you were an employee what is your
relationship with likewise the
relationship of talker with other
contributors how many do you
how do you handle them like other than
closing their PR okay what kind of
community how do you manage that
community and basically yeah so a lot of
our communication is over IRC we have a
channel just for maintainer switch is
where we take care of like more like
administrative tasks and then there's
the doctor dev channel where which is
where like we have the bots talking
about open PRS we have maintained errs
coming in and asking us like how they
should implement something or
contributors being like I hit this while
trying to build docker it's very like
only developing to Dockers yeah which is
really cool and then also like we have a
ton of bots on the repo that help us out
in terms of just the sheer volume of
pull request we get leavin we were
thinking of looking into what Cooper
Nettie's bought is because it looked
really cool but yeah I mean it's
actually really cool especially the
doctor core team in debt is employed by
docker as well because at every single
one of us was contributing to the
project before we worked there so as
much as people say like you know docker
is this enterprise company like we are
not if anything everyone else at doctor
thinks of us is like the hipster kids so
like we're very also very opinionated in
ourselves and it's nice to know that
like we all came from the community
first so if anything like my love for
the project will always exceed anything
else I want the project to be good and I
want to be something I want to use
personally and it is something that i
use personally so I mean yes great
everyday with every single efficient ya
go so how many just have an idea how
many maintainer is how many guns two
billion yeah um contributors there's
like in the thousands it's actually
gotten so big that github won't show
them off if you go on that page oh wow
it will only show like the top whatever
they show um so there's yeah ton
maintained errs there's maintained errs
of the
various like subsets of dr. itself but
for the docker engine I would say
there's definitely like five from dr.
the company and then there's about like
ten external from various companies like
IBM Red Hat and then also just
individuals themselves which is really
cool in students at universities even
our maintain errs nice that's very nice
yeah okay so to finish the interview I
had two questions which is about the
coolest things that you've seen so what
is the coolest talk or what's the
coolest thing you've learned during dr.
Khan oh man don't become so this talk
that I was just that actually this guy
was talking about how they run honey
pots in containers on their servers and
I was just like that's a really cool
concept before for the listeners that
the know what a honey pot is because
it's not a pot with honey is a honey pot
um it's like it's put there to kind of
try to catch hackers as like a hey come
this might be open for you um but he
didn't really go into details as to what
exactly there's were doing but it was
just interesting that they want to run
them in containers which is awesome but
to they just have them spread out on
their infrastructure everywhere nice so
it's basically a way of monitoring if
someone is actually attacking yeah it's
really that's really smart i really like
it and the other cool thing is what is
the coolest feature of docker for you
like but the thing that you love the
most um I mean I love all features but a
docker exactly like for some reason it
like means something personally to me
because it was like my first week
working at docker and granted i had
contributed to the project before but it
was a feature that I really wanted but
to i got assigned to it to try to help
it through the process and it was
actually fish from google who wrote the
PR itself and then i got to merge it is
super exciting and fun and it was like
two days before my birthday haha it's a
birthday present yeah it's a variety
keep us from the present reagan it's so
good now as well thank you so much for
taking your time to talk with us and see
you somewhere else in a different in a
different conference yeah thanks
good so thank you very much to you
Frances for setting up the interview and
Jesse for joining us I'm sure when I
listen to the episode in the future it
will be amazing and a both of you or me
I think it Thank You Jesse for taking
the time off a very very busy week at
dhaka come to have a chat with us yeah
so we have a great question of the week
from one of our previous listeners and
one time answer providers gentleman by
the name of Terrance using technical
solutions engineer here at Google the
answer good question like a debugging
question which I quite like which is
sort of this situation where it's like
why are my google compute engine
instance connect to a particular API or
resource like cloud sequel or bigquery
or cloud datastore and it could be
something that I think is probably
bitten me a couple times so I think it's
an excellent question yeah yeah I've
seen that before and I've heard people
asking those questions before so I think
it's a great question of the week so the
answer is actually quite simple it's
security by default when you create an
instance on compute engine the instant
will not have access to all the things
that you could do so we have it will
have access to some of the resources
that we also call scoped so for instance
what you created will have a read-only
access to a Google Cloud storage but
won't be able to write so so what did
you do if you want if you want that
instance to be able to write so the
easiest way is if you're creating an
instance through the development like
through the console to the web console
if you go to a tab when you create your
instance called access and security
you'll see all the levels of API access
you have there and as you said yeah you
can see that cloud sequel is none big
queries none by default storage is read
only because security right like you
want to keep things locked down and only
open up the things that you want to
which is great and that that's a really
easy way of saying oh yeah when I
created that instance before maybe I
forgot to like turn this on maybe I
should go have a little
it's a very quick you know it's sort of
a very common gotcha yea though I do
like the fact that now there is a button
it is allow API access to all Google
cloud services that's pretty handy
that's pretty handy but i could not
advise using it as a in general basis
yes it's very good if you want to have
an instance that you want to test that
your code is actually correct and it's
just an access problem or if you're
actually using that instance to do
development it's it's a great idea but
it's definitely not a good security
policy to allow access to all the Scopes
yeah exactly i think it's a great
troubleshooting feature you know like
let's let's make sure that this isn't
something that's the problem with what's
going on you know and then i can go back
and say okay let's let's scale these
security measures back and make sure
everything is the way it should be yeah
something interesting that none may be
some of our users don't know is when you
are this and the skirt that you were
talking about before when you create a
dialogue where you create a new instance
there's actually at the button if i
remember correctly something like
equivalent rest api or something like
that so I or an equiv like g-cloud man
so that actually show you how to do the
same thing through either to rest api so
it's going to be a JSON object or with
the jiggler command so that can be quite
useful if what you want to do is create
that instance with the scope that you
need from other from a place other than
the console itself oh that's nice I'm
actually looking at that now that's I
didn't quite realize that was there I
think I probably knew but I'd forgotten
but that's like a nice look sort of
interactive documentation quite a very
useful thing because sometimes i don't
remember exactly especially in the Jason
Jason formats like an hour where does it
go what's the parmiter in cheap loud to
create this thing so it's very very
handy yeah that's that's very very cool
I like that a lot so yeah if you if you
happen to run into a situation where
you think you've got your code right but
for whatever reason you can't access
cloud sequel or something like that from
compute engine make sure to go check
your scopes see if you have access that
way because you may not yeah very good
so to wrap up I would like to know what
are you up to next where where are you
going to be going doing what am I going
to be doing so when this episode
actually comes out I will be a closer
punch this time I think you and I are
doing very similar talks in just
different places we're talking about
wrapping developer tooling in dunkirk
containers which is a kind of funny yeah
that definitely a hot topic lately yeah
continue look you just gotta put
container on it and then you're fine but
it's what I've come down to but now
that's great and then I in december i
will be at dev fest in vancouver
December twelfth and thirteenth if
you're in the area come on down there
will be several of us if you da so it
should be a good time that sounds like
lots of fun so on my side I will
actually by the time this episode comes
up I will still be in Barcelona there
with the lab the last day of docker con
so that's where I'm heading on hanging
up tomorrow I'm going to Barcelona for
dr. Khan and and that's pretty much it
but i actually just wanted to mention
also that it just came back from devoxx
where one of our colleagues so diverts
in belgium one of our colleagues given
an amazing demonstration of cooper
Nettie's which we talked about last week
oh yeah I've heard about this yeah on a
cluster of raspberry PI's which is an
amazing demonstration you can basically
unplug cables and see how parts get
reallocated and so on it's an amazing
demo so I I will say if you have a
minute go check it out okay great we
have to put the video in the show notes
sounds fantastic well thank you once
again princess for joining me for
recording much appreciated well thank
you Mark for waking up so early I also
appreciate and it was a great pleasure
talking to you so see you all next week
see that
you
you